I'm trying to first of all just like
speak out so that you know I think it's
important to talk about because I think
it's made me feel less alone when other
women have come forward about being
sexually assaulted and also because you
know it's not this perfect rape like
people want the black you do what you do
in raped perfectly and they want you to
be a perfect victim but people hear me
say that and they go no but she's like a
son I bet she'd like right away you
start and you hear that from other women
of course yeah yeah there's the rape and
the rape rape right yeah they're just
like but you you didn't really and you
know we're so critical and it makes it
makes like victims really not want to
speak up and and so I think it's you
know it's me saying look I didn't have a
perfect rape but the way my virginity
was taken from me yeah and and it was
not in a cool way I was in and out of
sleep we were just kind of like lazily
watching TV we'd never had sex
oh and and I I could feel he was
touching me and I thought he was
fingering me and then it started to hurt
and I was like wow thank you I thought
you knew you know yeah um and that was
the end of the relationship or you
stayed in it no we stayed together I was
worried about him he felt really bad
about it and I was like I'm gonna kill
myself I'm so sorry and I meant okay but
it's like hey was he feeling bad about
it because he said oh I thought you were
awake or he fessed up and said no I know
what I did and I did the wrong thing um
he he knew that I didn't know he was
inside of me right it's really it's just
it's messed up yeah I'm in it and it's
not fair and that shouldn't have
happened to me I know and I hope it
stops it from happening to maybe even
one person